if you're doing your last-minute
Christmas shopping
be aware that labels can lie earlier
this year Sky News revealed major high
street stores were missed selling real
animal fur as synthetic I found rabbit
raccoon dog and mink everything is
characteristic of cat it's sort of
spotlights on supply chains and shots
consumers take a look at let's play in
lunch but after months of investigating
we found the problem is even worse
online a pair of earrings for a fiver
fast fashion appetizers faux by boohoo
but confirmed and testing to be mink our
investigation with with sky earlier this
year
really put the fake faux fur scandal on
the map what we found in the run-up to
Christmas is dozens of trusted retailers
online selling enormous numbers of items
describing them as fake but they're
actually turning out to be real animal
fur these are some of the biggest and
best-known online retailers absolutely
I'm TK Maxx who have a loafer policy we
found this coat for sale online
described as fake fur but when we've had
the collar the trim tested it it turned
out to be false
we were also contacted by a concerned
shopper he bought this pom-pom keyring
she asked TK Maxx to investigate and
they assured her it was though but our
testing found it was rabbit and they
weren't the only ones very
disappointingly boohoo you know we
applaud them for having a no fur policy
but unfortunately in these occasions
they haven't adhered to that bridal
shoes made of rabbit this bobble hat
from miss Bardot sold and described as
faux fur of only eight pounds but when
we've had this bubble tested it's
actually fox fur we also found
mislabeled fur sold on Amazon and
Groupon so clearly current regulations
are just not robust enough no and brexit
gives us the opportunity to close our
borders to the cruel unnecessary and
outdated fur trade we've banned fur
farming in the UK back in 2000 because
it was deemed unethical why we're now
paying people in countries like China
and Poland to keep animals in those
exact same conditions
all the retailers highlighted say they
have no fur policies would never
knowingly mislead customers and removed
the items we featured we took our
findings to Parliament and found a
cross-party selection of MPs you now
want the government to act we simply
need to have a ban on fur coming in from
other countries one of the things that
your investigation really did reveal was
the fact that this fur can be imported
incredibly cheaply which probably just
speaks to really appalling conditions
that those animals are kept in it is
crazy that we banded here and that we're
still upon sill permitting input with
the retailer it's no good it's not a
it's not an excuse to say oh we didn't
know don't we'll find out
we shouldn't be important these products
people shouldn't be behind them on
wittily companies certainly shouldn't be
selling them styles change every season
but the Miss labeling of fur is a
growing trend in fashion and it may take
consumer power for that to stop sorry
Gary Sky News